hier draußen im ländlichen West Virginia
da ticken die Uhren noch anders das alte
Amerika ist hier zu Hause konservativ
werteorientiert christlich weiß
Gary scheinholz ist apfelphama und ein
sehr großer Fan des ehemaligen
Präsidenten Trump
sie wollen ihm die Schuld für alles
geben aber es ist doch ihr eigenes
Versagen es ist wie bei seiner Politik
er regt die Eliten und den ganzen Sumpf
einfach auf sie können ihn nicht
ertragen
Gary macht eine Bestellung fertig für
einige Jäger die faule Äpfel bekommen um
damit das Wild anzulocken er würde gerne
Trump als Präsidenten wieder haben aber
er hat auch Mitleid mit ihm
sie werden doch nur wieder hinter ihm
her sein genau wie vorher
zu seinem eigenen besten würde er sich
besser zur Ruhe setzen und sein Leben
genießen und diesen ganzen Mist nicht
noch mal hinnehmen
doch Trump selbst sieht das anders meint
er werde als Präsident gebraucht um das
Land zu retten Washington aber hat er
den Kampf angesagt
will uns zum Schweigen bringen aber das
lassen wir nicht zu
was wir über die letzten sechs Jahre
aufgebaut haben ist die größte Bewegung
der Geschichte denn sie dient nicht der
Politik sondern unserer Liebe zu diesem
großartigen Land
durch die früher Ankündigung will er
Gegenkandidaten auf Abstand halten und
hofft auch auf Schutz vor
Strafverfolgung
er ist ein Betrüger dann noch ein
Gangster aber noch vor dem Betrüger ist
der ein Irrer er kandidiert für sein Ego
und weil er damit Geld machen kann er
nichts nach Macht und hat kein Gefühl
von Verantwortung weder für seine Partei
noch fürs Land
und vielen Republikanern reicht das
jetzt seit er das Sagen hat in der
Partei haben sie nicht mehr die Mehrheit
in beiden Parlamentskammern gewonnen
außerdem gegen Joe Biden verloren
sie haben Angst dass mit Trump keine
Wahlen mehr zu gewinnen sind
Donald Trump sagte wir werden mit ihm so
viel gewinnen aber alles was er macht
ist verlieren
die Rechten murdock-medien die ihm als
dröhnendes sprachrohrdienten verspotten
ihn die New York Post zeigt Trump in
Anlehnung an einen Kinderreim als
Eierkopf Trump die Dumpty der von einer
Mauer fällt und wendet sich der Zukunft
zu die sie im erfolgreichen Gouverneur
Floridas ronde Säntis sieht selbst eine
Ikone der rechten Scharfmacher Laura
Ingram lässt Trump fallen
[Musik]
populistischen Bewegung geht es um Ideen
nicht um eine Person
wenn die Wähler merken dass man sein Ego
und seinen Groll über das stellt was gut
für das Land ist schauen sie sich eben
anderweitig um Punkt
denn 58 Prozent der Amerikaner sehen in
Trumps Bewegung eine Gefahr für die
Demokratie
ihnen bereitet das Unbehagen der
Personenkult Trumps längst widerlegte
wahllüge abgedrehte
Verschwörungstheorien für gemäßigte
Republikaner nicht mehr wählbar doch die
Republikaner brauchen beide Lager um
Wahlen zu gewinnen die gemäßigten und
diese transisten und wehe die Partei
wendet sich von Trump ab
er würde alles abfackeln wenn die
Republikaner ihn zurückweisen wird er
eine sehr zerstörerische Kraft
damit hat er bereits begonnen Gouverneur
Ron des Säntis hat in Florida einen
virtuosen Sieg für die Republikaner
errungen große Geldgeber um schwärmen
ihn sein Spitzname Trump mit Hirn der
einzige vielleicht der auch die treuen
magerwähler für die Partei zurückholen
könnte eine Gefahr für Trump der sofort
um sich schlägt es wäre ein Fehler wenn
rondes Sand ist kandidieren würde und
weiter ich werde euch Dinge über ihn
sagen die nicht sehr schmeichelhaft sind
ich weiß mehr über ihn als jeder
er will keinen Gegenkandidaten will von
seiner Partei auf die Kandidatur gehoben
werden gleichsam wie auf einen Thron
Donald Trump beobachtet gerissen ob
seine innerparteilichen Gegner schwach
sind und nicht gegenhalten können ich
weiß nicht ob Disentis und andere
antreten werden sie konnten Angst haben
aber Sie sollten kandidieren denn wir
müssen die republikanische Partei von
der Assoziation mit Trump lösen und es
beweisen indem wir uns ihm
entgegenstellen
bislang aber sind die Republikaner immer
wieder eingeknickt
Ärger in der Partei als Trump mit
diktatorenkumpelte
Irritation als er bei einem Protest
gegen Neonazis von sehr feinen Leuten
auf beiden Seiten sprach
Schock als er versuchte die Ukraine zu
erpressen um Schmutz über die beiden zu
bekommen
und blanker Terror als er den
Abgeordneten im Capitol einen Mob auf
den Hals hätte
nichts davon hat den Republikanern
gereicht um Abstand zu nehmen sie hätten
mit der Amtsenthebung eine weitere
Kandidatur verhindern können aber sie
sind eingeknickt freigesprochen
woher sollen sie dann diesmal den Mut
nehmen sich ihm entgegenzustellen
denn die parteifunktionärer haben Angst
vor Wählern wie Gary schernholz die sie
nicht verlieren wollen aber deren
Loyalität Trump gehört und nicht der
Partei
die Bewegung ist das wichtige die
America first Bewegung das ist nicht die
republikanische Partei sondern das sind
Trumps mager Leute nicht die
Republikaner in Washington
nicht das republikanische ist Tablet hat
diesen Geist gerufen den es nun nicht
mehr los wird sondern Menschen wie Gary
Wähler wie ihn müssen die Republikaner
überzeugen wenn sie Trump wirklich
hinter sich lassen möchten
[Musik]